The prophet Muhammad sallallah.aii
wasallam told us that whoever builds a
mosque for Allah, Allah will build for
him a sim at a house in Jenna. And we
know the great reward that will not only
be gained but rather will fill your
grave after your death. Whenever someone
prays there, whenever someone gives
shahada in the masid, whenever someone
learns something in the masid, yes, that
will be something that you'll have on
your scale.
[Music]
How are you guys doing? Russell Brand is
ironically a person who tried to rebrand
himself after some serious allegations
were held against him and his left-wing
base uh had actually cancelled him in a
sense and he had grown disgruntled with
them to the point now where he's hosted
a contemptable uh junkie in Tommy
Robinson. uh he's hosted him on his
platform to spew misinformation
uh to his followers. Let's take a look
at a clip which I found which I thought
was quite ridiculous and come back and
respond in kind.
>> And there's a march of Palestine and
there's thousands of Muslims coming out
and they're chanting kaoba kauba kauba
and I'm thinking what are they chanting?
So I asked my mate what are they talking
about there? And they said, well, Kaiba
was a Jewish tribe. Yeah. In the time of
Muhammad. And Muhammad, they
surrendered. Muhammad beheaded 600 of
them. So they killed them all. And the
leader of the tribe was called Canana.
And this is in and when I started
studying Islam and I picked up the
biography of Muhammad by Ibishtak. It's
the most renowned biography in the world
of the prophet Muhammad. I picked up and
when I read it, he a Jewish tribe
surrender and then they pulled their
pants down. Anyone who started puberty,
they killed. Yeah. They behead. But then
he took the leader Cananano. He tortured
him. He burns his chest. This is in
Islamic scripture. He sets fire to him
and takes his gold. Yeah. He's a pirate.
The man's a pirate. Yeah. He's a warlord
and a pirate. But he takes his gold.
After taking his gold, he then takes his
wife that night, Sophia, and he takes
her as his his wife. Yeah. It's not like
she she wasn't a willing participant in
this. Surely not. Yeah. But so as all
this going on, I'm seeing him chanting
Kaoba. So I understood the hatred of the
Jews. And then as I looked at the Quran,
now the Quran is 7%. No, mine camp
Hitler's book is 7% Jew hatred. The
Quran is 11 11%. So there's a big
problem here. Yeah. Muhammad didn't like
the Jews. Forget Israel. Muhammad didn't
like the Jews. It's it's all in the
scripture. It's in Muhammad's life. So
when Israel happened then I went to
Israel. I don't know if you've been
there. You've been there. So we have
heard this contemptable junkie, this
uneducated buffoon speak about Islam
before as if he's some kind of an
academic. When I was studying Islam, I
saw such and such as a this very famous
uh you know book of biography of the
prophet which is the most famous one,
most important one and he pronounces it
incorrectly.
uh it's actually and he pronounces it
Ishak which is incorrect and then he
mentions something within it and
claiming it's authoritative the supposed
torturing of this individual called Kana
by the prophet Muhammad himself
supposedly not realizing that this is a
fabricated and inauthentic narration
that no Muslim accepts let alone
considers as part of their scripture and
then you have this individual
uh sitting there kind of smiling, you
know, trying to appease Tommy Robinson,
trying to get a new crowd to be to be
favorable to him because, as we
mentioned, he's been spat out really by
the left wing. He has grown to be
disgruntled with his previous friends
and compatriots and colleagues because
of the very serious allegations of a
sexual kind that have been held at him.
and now he's rebranding as a kind of you
know Christian guy and a clean guy and
this and you know talking about Christ
and all these kind of things that's all
fine well and good but don't do it at
the expense of Islam or the Muslim
population you can have whatever
religion you want but don't sit there
and listen to a contemptable junkie
giving providing no push back whatsoever
about issues which he's absolutely
incorrect so he mentions this about Kana
we've we've already corrected him on
this and then he's got something else he
has to say which is that he then took
Safy and such and such. This is
incorrect.
There are many hadiths. In fact, one of
them is in Bkari which is the most
authoritative collection after the Quran
which clearly mentions that Safy
who was a Jewish woman and who the
prophet sallallaihi wasallam married
himself and he mentions that Muhammad
hated the Jews. if he hated them so
much, why did he marry an a woman who's
ethnically Jewish and in fact told her
many times how to defend herself against
some other accusations against her. And
that's another story for another time
relating to her Jewishness. In fact, he
told her how to defend herself against
that.
But then he gave her a choice and this
is in a many many hadiths. In fact, one
of them says, "Choose what you want. You
can become Muslim. You can go you can go
back to your family. It's no problem at
all. And in fact, if you go back to your
family, it's not an issue. You will not
be held to account. You will you will be
freed. You'll be freed. The prophet told
Safi Ab.
And we've mentioned this before. So
you're a liar and we have our sources
and you have no sources and you're an
uneducated man. You haven't even done
your GCES. So that's one thing. The
other thing that should be said is that
Brand himself now has come out and said
the following. I'm going to read this
out actually. And he put this on his
Twitter.
He states, "Britain has 1,000 years of
Christian history. Yet in just decades,
it's been dismantled.
Across the Islamic world, minorities
have no rights. Once Islam is the
majority, why gamble with Britain's
future? Protect British people first.
That's not something a direct quotation
from Tommy Robinson. This is or these
are the very words of Russell Brand
himself.
So, let's take a look at what he says.
He says, "Britain has 1,000 years of
Christian history, but it's been but in
just decades, it's been dismantled." And
then he mentions Islam after. And
someone could say the implication is
that you are blaming Islam for the
dimunition of Christianity
demographically in this country. If you
look at the census data of this country
from 2001 to 2011 from my recollection
in 2001 there was about 71 or 72%
Christian people in this country that
went down and in 2011 and went down once
again to some 40ome%
in the 2021 census. These people did not
convert to Islam. Yes, Islam went from
about 2% to about six and a half% in
population, but that's because of uh
mostly birth rates actually. That's the
reason why that increase has happened.
So why are you connecting the fact that
people no longer want to practice your
religion with the religion of Islam? Why
are you connecting the two things
together? Then you start speaking about
minority rights in the Islamic world.
There have been times in 1,400 years of
Islamic history where there have been
collaborative and harmonious
relationships with Muslims and
Christians. We know that for example in
Andalusians and I'm sure he know he went
to so he done a part-time master's
degree for 5 years. I think he done one
master's degree or something. It's took
him five years to complete which is
brand but at least he done something
with his life.
That's how long it took him. And so I'm
sure he would have read these kinds of
things. He he knows that when
even according to Thomas Arnold Walker
who was an orientalist in his book the
preaching of Islam went into Jerusalem
that he greeted everybody and he allowed
everyone to practice their religion.
That's a that's the prophetam's friend
and companion. And the second after the
prophet Muhammad wasallam, he knows that
he knows that Aub according to
essentially every source after
Jerusalem had been overtaken for 88
years by the crusades and Salahaden had
come back in and after he had conquered
the crusades. He told those people, the
Christians and the Jews that they can
come in at any time to this city. And
the Christians were astounded because
they was they thought that they were
going to be dealt with in the same way
as the Crusades dealt with the Muslims,
which is to slaughter them and to
destroy them. That didn't happen. Of
course, there are times in Islamic
history where you had the and you I'm
not even going to count this in Islamic
history, but you have ISIS and you have
radical factions. I'm not denying that.
But there are also times as we mentioned
with the Crusades, with the Spanish
Inquisition, many different instances
and what's going on today in Christian
and Jewish history where Muslims have
been at the receiving end of, you know,
all kinds of oppression from Christian
and Jewish people. Minorities in general
can be mistreated and minorities in
general could be treated very well. But
making this generalization and talk
about minority rights in a weak way,
unacademic way
is not an argument. And why don't you be
a man brand? Why don't you be a man? If
you have these views against Islam or
Muslims or whatever it may be, why don't
you be a man and have a discussion with
some Muslim about this? Why are you
cowering behind the likes of Tommy
Robinson, the contemptable chav, the
contemptable
junkie? Why are you cowering? Why are
you trying to cower behind these more
alpha figures? Because let's be honest,
you're not that guy. You're not that
guy. So now you're trying to appeal to
the far right. By the way, your brand,
the way you are, your temperament, your
disposition, the far right will never
accept you because you're weak. You're a
weak personality. Okay? And you you've
easily been sold. And some people have
been saying saying to you that you're
saying that, you know, you've been
taking money from this source and that
source. Maybe some people have been have
been saying that you they have something
on you
and you know what I'm talking about.
Huh? You know what I'm talking about
brand. So don't come and and talk about
Islam. Don't go there. Yeah. Don't go
there and start speaking about Islam.
You're not that guy. You don't have that
kind of a knowledge. You or your
contemptable chav friend that you're
trying to appease because you're trying
to get a new base with the far right
because you know you're nothing now to
the left wing that you used to be.
You've been rejected by them and soon
enough you'll be completely irrelevant.
By the way, brand you are going to be
completely I predict you are going to be
completely irrelevant. The left wing
don't like you. The minorities and the
Muslims don't like you now. And guess
who else is not going to like you? The
right-wing and the far right are not
going to like you because you are not
their cup of tea. You are the kind of
thing that they consider to be a
parasite and the kind of thing that they
consider to be a waste of time
in British society. A weak man that's
how they consider you and that's what
you arealam.
Hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again? Your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a masid a da center.
Establishing a masjid to convey the
message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do. There's a huge
need for it in Norway. You know this and
I know this. So that makes the reward
even greater. So give generously and
Allahawel will give you even more.